[Music]
hey hey folks here we are we might be
drunk you know where it is you know what
it is we got a couple of tequila sodas
and it's just us today boys
no salacuse salacuse has something with
his dumb kid i don't know school who can
keep up [ __ ] yeah right good to be here
though uh good to see you man i saw you
briefly last night
yeah that's right we went and saw
ronan's uh taping at the vu killer run
on hershberg look out for coming out
soon crushed it crushed it it was fun
it's fun to watch because like we were
in that mix i guess you're still in that
mix yeah but it was this is his first
youtube and so he was like jazzed up he
was nervous he was pacing it was great
yeah i went to the early show it's good
to see someone crush a special and then
they're just kind of like done yeah i
mean not dumb but like he had one of the
cans like you you got it oh yeah and i
heard the second we were at the first
one but i heard this the second one i
went and saw like 20 minutes of it and
it was even hotter so
it's gonna be great gonna be great man
great jokes we got packages do people
keep sending us stuff at gotham we
forget to open all of them on
uh painting the patreon so should i open
this yeah that's a big boy you got there
holy oh my god it's more popcorn this is
called cuse corn like syracuse is orange
and blue ah
orange and blueberry white chocolate
dude this [ __ ] is so good oh you could
call it q's corn like salakus that's
true cheddar oh yeah classic the amount
of popcorn they send wow that's a lot of
cheddar this is nav's popcorn in uh
thousand islands new york hard island
peanut butter and milk chocolate that's
my number one right there
classic just buttered oh classic's good
too i'm gonna have one bite of this and
then kill myself
sour patch ah i gotta try it try sour
patch try it try it try it i don't know
what i'm chanting i could just try it
let's see holy hell
oh
peanut butter milk chocolate not my
favorite all right
it's a little too i don't know why yeah
it's like weird yeah i'm not a big sour
patch guy anyway you're not
yeah i have one i'm good these flavors
kettle milk chocolate
new york mix caramel and white cheddar
because we're gentrified here in new
york baby you got that right diversity
what else i mean this is so much so good
caramel
wow
don't know what this this will be
another caramel this is good what a
great gift i'm saying this [ __ ] fireball
oh boy
you're gonna ship blood with that one
i'm a jager bomb
what else kettle
yeah i mean this is crazy well these
guys make great popcorn i've had it the
only one i don't like is the sour patch
yeah love the pod enjoy some popcorn
next time you're enjoying a movie had
fun hosting for mark a few months back
i enjoyed working with you guys back at
carolina oh caroline sorry hit me up if
you ever need a host or feature when
you're upstate brian eng thank you so
much brian this is amazing and it really
is great popcorn it is all right brian
new york i'm gonna try the new york mix
yeah
[ __ ] yeah dude
popcorn doing a movie that is like oh
unbeatable
you know that pull this up there chachi
i heard there's this thing now when you
smell popcorn pop it in the distance in
a microwave what do you think
i might what i don't know well like is
it good or bad it's great it's great
every american says it's great but in
europe they smell popcorn popping and
it's gross
i don't know what it is like the
upbringing the diet it's kind of like
cilantro it goes either way is that true
yeah i'm telling you european smell
popcorn they hate it
yeah this is amazing
what a fun weird it's like one of those
weird little phenomenon things yeah i
love popcorn oh i grew up eating my dad
ate popcorn every day i feel like it's
not it's not as bad for you as a lot of
the others i mean obviously this stuff's
not great for you well yeah
i don't the two i love the buttered
popcorn but dude i feel like horrible
after it oh yeah
it's like having sex without a condom
right you're just like what have i done
to myself yeah but it was good while it
lasted
and you look at your fingers
[Laughter]
oh that's good
taste that down a little tequila yeah i
need some coffee first oh yeah
there you go these early afternoon
episodes are taking a toll my friend
yeah well the funny thing about the
coffee is like you got a stimulant and
then you got a depressant yeah you know
we're just putting all these i end up
back in the middle there you go yeah
it's tough on the body oh my god
it really it really is tequila they say
is an upper we've been
i i hope to believe that but uh hey man
thank you so much for sending this uh
popcorn
nothing ah maybe i made that up have you
you were in indianapolis
yeah how was it i tell you that's a
boring town it really is you know
they're all about the cults and whatnot
um but nice people
great comedy crowds good comedy crowds
so we sold out a couple of them had a
great i had umar had sean murphy we just
had one of those hangs where you like we
don't even need the town we sat in the
green room for like eight hours after
the show we're drunk we're high we're
full we ate all these chicken wings and
whatnot we're like kids umar fell asleep
on the floor i love it uh you know you
peed your pants i pissed my pants i woke
up blowing shawn murphy and
we're like we should probably get out of
here because you know there's probably
some poor staff member waiting for us we
leave we walk out of the green room it's
all dark the alarm goes off they forgot
we were back there oh man that's how
long we hung out the alarm
we go what the [ __ ] we're in we're at a
dark club alone at like four in the
morning and we just ran home
we just ran to our hotel
yeah i remember in indianapolis i was
there once years ago there's a lot of
violence in downtown indiana oh yeah
they like to brag it's funny they love
to brag they're like more murders per
capita than chicago i'm like that's not
a good thing i know why you're telling
me that with a smile on your face you
remember going to the hotel and the
uh it was blocked off and i kind of was
like is there like why is it blocked
open the cop was like some kids were
shooting around i'm like yeah that's not
shooting that's basketball that's not
guns dude that's not how you describe
murder right that's true shooting around
like a game like cowboys and indians
they have morden's steakhouse not
morton's that what's what's the famous
uh
saint elmo's saint elmo's i went there
that steak is pretty crazy i think it's
from 1902 that's a bomb-ass steak great
steak yeah and like that's like a
classic old-timey like you get your
scotch and your steak your martini and
your steak it's it's old school old
school right downtown too right in all
the all the business centers and uh i
love you know the story of roots chris
no pull this off oh yeah you told me
this but i forgot it tell me maybe i
told you we do a podcast where we drink
this was
[Laughter]
this is what i you know we like a lot of
like strong female lead [ __ ] now if i
was making a movie and i needed a female
story i would do this story
this lady ruth
her husband chris left her and her three
kids alone so she had to like make it on
her own she was cooking steaks on a hot
plate
it got so popular because she cooked a
hell of a steak she named it ruth's
chris like i own you [ __ ] wow
you left me high and dry and it just
built and built it became like a new new
orleans staple and then she started a
chain now she's a zillionaire i will say
i get the name now but not knowing that
story it's a pretty dumb name horrible
name i hate saying it i do too ruth
chris i can't even say it it's too much
ruth it's like a tongue twister i'm with
you man it is a nightmare chris i guess
you could say it but it's like chris
yeah you just say it fast yeah new
orleans 65. steakhouse for sale 18 grand
north broad and earthline which is now a
horrific neighborhood but it's a good
steak too it is it's expensive
um
but fun story yeah it's a good story
yeah but yeah indy uh
crowds came out but it was cool chris d
was at some theater
uh
goldman was in a different theater i'm
at the club it was like a real comedy
weekend so chris d came by we hung out
he's sober now so he he said however
well he's trying
wow yeah he's going for it i think he's
20 days in
good for him yeah so he came by and
that's tough made jokes about fauci and
then he left and uh yeah we just had a
great time so brian man anyone trying to
be sober respect it ain't easy
no especially you know the hardest part
about being sober is still going and
doing [ __ ] yes being around people sober
that ain't easy
no it's tough especially at night time i
remember telling my therapist once like
man it's hard to be around people sober
he's like yeah you got to work on that
like that's uh
that's hard yeah he's like he's like you
can't just uh you can't just say you
can't just he's like that's on you to
connect with people i'm like well some
people are tough yeah of course
but he's right i mean it's we're social
creatures and all that but like all we
do is hang out at bars comedy clubs
nightlife so like but we're introverts
and that's why we drink exactly because
we don't i don't think we like it
naturally no i like to be home i don't
like to do anything no i had a
weekly poker game when i was in college
with like literally like 15 guys would
play poker i would get blacked out every
time and all my friends like what are
you doing you got to like get it
together you can't even play a game of
poker without yakking and i'm like
i'm sitting there with 20 guys or 15
guys for five hours i'm freaking out
yeah your friend loses 15 grand he looks
at you he's like you have a problem
poker is really i have a friend who used
to you know that degenerate friend who
would just show up like he would text me
the [ __ ] the minnesota links lost i'm
like you're betting on the wnba
you've got a problem dude
he was that type of dude i grew up with
him phil's met him a few times so
hanley's met him he's a character but
he's a degenerate gambler he's really
funny he's a funny guy but uh gamblers
are funny and they are because they're
very self-deprecating they're very
cynical i mean yep and then take risks
that's a wreck hang out with
self-deprecating people because they'll
make you laugh oh yeah nothing worse
than like insecure people who are just
uh
who are just like kind of braggarts
it's weird the thing that like people a
lot of people like consider someone cool
and they're so clearly insecure i know
isn't that weird that's interesting
where they're like man that guy's cool
i'm like that dude hates himself he just
doesn't know it yet yes exactly if he
was if he was more self-aware he'd
realize how much he hated himself then
he'd be cool yes here here they act hip
and cool all the time and you're like
dude i can tell you're a nerd i can tell
you're at home like practicing this [ __ ]
looking in the mirror putting on outfits
and jewelry and all this horse [ __ ]
just hang this
this dude's hilarious like he he didn't
know how i remember he texted me once he
was like um it was years ago he's like
man i just woke up next to a hooker and
a crack pipe and i was like dude that's
horrible you gotta get help he goes what
i'm being self-deprecated i was like
that's not self-deprecating that's like
a cry for help
self-deprecating
but he was a funny dude i mean i
remember he just showed up at a gig i
was at atlantic city and i'm just i come
out of the show a gig i got stiffed on
by the way
uh i was there for like damn five or six
days uh
ac yeah yeah the guy disappeared
tropicana oh boy he owes people way more
money than me though i've heard multiple
people talk about this guy yeah
there's any justice he's in a car about
to get whacked right now but uh i think
he's on the subway this morning
you just wish you had a friend
you just wish he had a friend like furio
to show up
yeah put a beat down on him hell yeah
yeah the two best gamblers are artie
lang and norm mcdonald two hilarious
guys well already had the best stories
i've ever already had that bit about how
uh he's like you wanna you wanna make a
game exciting put a thousand dollars in
the giant when you got 500 in the
check-in
he's like you're gonna care about that
game oh yeah but that's a rush i mean
that's like something where you're like
oh that's that's a problem it's funny my
friend will lose all this money and then
he'll just say [ __ ] like i had no
regrets and i'm like no regrets it's
it's not a relationship you just lost
money yeah i don't get it i get the high
and i get the
baby the hope and the feeling and the
the blood pumping but when you lose 500k
it's gone like i read norm's book and he
talked about losing like i don't know
hundred thousand dollars which is all
the money he had and he's like that's a
lot of money to lose yeah he's like i
walked out to the ocean and i was like i
feel clean now i'm gonna go make more
money but i feel clean i got it i'm like
that's the dumbest thing i've ever heard
insane you could have donated to a
charity that's right and and still felt
you would've got cleaner yeah but that's
clean there's no rush you know you don't
write that children's hospital check
like oh baby
that's no fun on that
i remember when he
norm i think he made it to the finals of
uh who wants to be a millionaire and he
bailed on he bailed on the last one
because it wasn't his money and you're
like oh that's a good dude if it was his
money he would have gone for it and won
at all yeah because he was right he was
right that's such a great episode i've
stolen a joke he does that uh just in
conversation where
uh
one of the facts comes at one of the
questions and
regis goes oh you know uh the guitar was
actually invented blah blah and norm
goes it's very uninteresting
simplest sentence but it's so funny
because no one talked like that on that
show it's great it's very uninteresting
and he's like
that's very understanding i've been
insulting someone that bluntly
and also that like in a polite manner is
such a great way to insult someone so
good so good norm was cool is it cute he
was like burt reynolds he was chewing
gum and he's like
the lights go down and everything and he
was ah was so great he was a cool
handsome guy i know he was everything
comics aren't like he was religious he
was i think pretty conservative he was
uh funny as hell cool laid-back
he didn't self-deprecate i mean he was
he was different yeah
but he would self-deprecate i mean like
it wasn't like in a i'm like a loser but
he would yeah i mean he was
i mean i remember when he got fired i
mean he he read the situation as it was
remember he got fired from weekend
update he was very self-deprecating on
you know on letterman's uh on the couch
yeah yeah on the panel well he had an
interesting way of doing it because don
olmeyer was like you're not funny and
and norm's you think he's gonna go [ __ ]
you i am funny but norm goes i'm not
that's horrible
that's why he's a genius he's punished
he's like damn i'm in this comedy
business i'm ruined am i funny i had no
idea so sarcastic yeah but sarcasm is
kind of a form of self-deprecation
that's true i mean uh
yeah it was great the gambling thing is
so crazy to me like michael jordan
degenerate gambler oh yeah it's crazy i
guess with him it doesn't really matter
because he's just never going to stop
printing money but true but it's a it's
definitely a disease like he would be uh
playing golf and they would gamble like
who would get their drink first like he
couldn't stop with mj yeah
that's hilarious like little things like
let's bet on uh you know who can
what like let's put on what bird chirps
quickest you know there's like three
birds it was crazy [ __ ] where you're
like dude we're betting on birds now
it's bananas
that is a sickness that is uh it's weird
to be
because like
competitiveness i understand like jordan
best basketball player ever
competitive as [ __ ] worked honed his
craft and then you're doing something
that's just random yeah you have the
same competitive fire over over like i
get my i bet my drink comes first and
you're like that's just it makes no
sense to me it makes no sense but that's
the disease you know we i need more what
else what else you know let's put on
this let's put on that you're like dude
relax we played 18 roll holes of golf
you're playing in a game tomorrow on the
on the court
we got competition you're good
yeah you couldn't stop
yeah it's like golf i get because that's
the same sure but
over nothing a lot of young players went
broke hanging out with jordan wow well
it's like imagine you're hanging out
with like your comedy hero yeah and then
he's like mark uh
i bet i have a better set than you and
i'm going to put 125 can it and you're
like well i want to keep hanging out
with him that's true that's true
remember the last dance he's literally
throwing quarters against the wall with
the security guard like in the back you
got a game coming up you should be
stretching or something and you're
throwing [ __ ] nickels at the wall
it's such a different type of dude than
i am it's so funny i i don't have that
at all and i'm glad i don't i'm glad it
doesn't seem peaceful i go to a casino
with my my friend growing up
mike was like the big casino guy and
he's like ding ding he's like you hear
all that that's money that sounds like
money i'm like timmy that sounds like
losing
you know big wheels
yeah he was a nut i mean he's he's doing
all right now but he was a real real
game all right now but last week was in
rough shape i'll tell you no he that
that's what this dude was like he
wouldn't care when he lost he was ah you
live by the sword you die by the sword
i'm like i think you live by a woman
with an oxygen tank and you die by a
woman with an oxygen i don't think this
is the sword exactly i think you've got
a gambling addiction i mean
i do you do play it though when you get
why people like
poker's fun poker's awesome
camaraderie it's social yeah blackjack's
cool it's like here we go what's gonna
happen but
those those machines
i mean that's just sad that one i don't
get because that one just seems so
clearly rigged and i'm not slot shaming
but
i'm just saying
it's so rigged you got to sit there for
three days if you want to win 20 bucks
yeah it's like it just feels like it's
literally like you're flushing your
money like that's what that action feels
like it's like a flush there should be a
toilet going
yep exactly and then
just to get some kind of wind you just
chug drinks because you're like i gotta
get something out of this and now i'm
hammered and losing money the free booze
yeah yeah that really that really
cushions the blow and you lose uh five
grand you're like well i had four
cranberry vodkas
i showed them i know
those the cocktail waitress must clean
up because yeah you know i'm just
tipping like crazy because it's free so
i'm like here's a five here's a here's
eight here's six
but i'm yeah you're right when you're
losing i mean that's the thing when
you're winning you really ride that wave
like you really are like you're generous
and when you're losing you're like well
[ __ ] it i lost what's money i lost it
anyway you know yeah it's they really
take the power out of money i mean i was
with a friend recently and he did you
know over the weekend he just he won a
bunch of money in poker and he's like
[ __ ] it drinks on you know yeah yeah but
that i'm like no because yep if you lost
you know you wouldn't be you know yeah
you wouldn't just be like you're
covering the whole night right exactly
and then it's a weird thing where they
give you stuff if you win
remember that blew my mind the first
time i saw like we're gonna give you the
sweet and the the breakfast and the
buffet for free because you're winning
and then somebody told me yeah they do
that so you keep gambling and i was like
and you lose it and then you lose it
blew my mind damn you know when your
friend's a real animal is when you're
like i don't know i don't want to go to
casino and he goes
i'll take out 300 and i'll take out 100
for you because i want you to gamble
with me like if you win the 100 give it
back to me if you win two you get 100. i
had a friend like that once and he's a
famous comedian yeah and uh it was
hilarious he goes whatever you make he's
like he's like if you lose at all no
hard feelings and if you win anything we
split it there you go this guy's already
like enterprising over here you know
he's putting other people to work yeah
this guy's a genius i know it's pretty
good but if you lose he has to eat it
but that money's nothing to him i guess
so if you're doing that
oh yeah
casinos they're talking about building
them in in the city now you know which
would be crazy i mean new york isn't
that wasn't there an article about that
in new york city well they're uh i mean
because they're trying to make money in
the city again because you know think
about how much money is wrapped up in
office space which they're losing
because so many
what people are working what max three
days in office a week now yeah way down
way down so much is on zoom i mean new
york city has casinos like that's that's
more money i guess but ugh
yeah yeah i don't know we're not
bringing in a quality crowd it's a bad
crowd what is it cleveland has that
casino about four blocks from the club
and as you get one block two block
closer it's like sketchier sketchier
hobo
uh you know degenerate gambler if people
get their paycheck go right there that's
the sad thing yeah that friday is packed
there yeah it really is cow well then
also uh yeah i remember reno nevada that
casino uh
they they want to pick me up for morning
radio at like 6 a.m and i'm outside and
i'm like the other dudes out here at 6
00 am are not people i want to be near
no these dudes are on meth
i mean
it was sketchy a lot of like fast
walking you're like oh [ __ ] i know right
that's the only exercise they're getting
in reno is fast meth walking like this
it's true unless they're leaving my show
it's the same speed
but the smoking too i hate that just
being in a warehouse with ding-ding-ding
bad carpet weird sad people and smoke
it's a nightmare but it'd be weird to
not allow smoking when you're allowing
all that true yeah yeah man i bombed
every show there it was like it was it
does wonders on your soul where you're
like man uh not only am i bombing i
haven't seen outside right
oh and people say go for a walk no you
go for a walk see if you come back
i know man so true vegas bums me out
vegas is a little better because it's
sunny as hell there's restaurants you
know but
when you go a little outside the strip
it's kind of vegas can be cool yeah yeah
but like i you realize you haven't seen
a tree in three days you know what reno
is you know every politician has that
[ __ ] up younger brother yeah that's
reno
reno's the one we're like dude reno's
got to get it together reno's
that's true it's like hunter biden you
know you're like jeez take it easy come
on hun
yeah
yeah hunter biden and uh tom or john
what's his [ __ ] name donald jr yeah
both [ __ ] up every oh every
politician's son is
bush w yeah yeah he was a cokehead yeah
but he got a letter he was the president
yeah
that was a great movie w
was it good really good brolin killed it
it's really he plays bush yeah and uh oh
and uh who plays cheney oh
pull that up i can't remember i saw it i
saw it was that adam mckay
no that was uh a different movie which
was great
brolin elizabeth banks oh yeah
geez
jeffrey wright colin powell i could see
that
colin hanks
was dreyfus cheney yes oh look at that
yeah dreifus is good yeah he's good but
uh the latest one with adam mckay i
forgot operation vice verse vice versa
it was just vice i didn't see it it's
heavy but it's good i saw it in the
theater
but you're like jesus christ
it's it's very dense with political [ __ ]
but it's interesting
oh yeah and bale played cheney and
killed it man who's changed his body
more than who's changed their body more
christian baler oprah
i was just gonna you beat me to it yeah
so true maybe jonah hill
yeah he's up there with weight he
changes a lot yeah yeah jonah hill's
[ __ ] great and everything he's so
good and no one talks about how great he
is i feel like people talk about it oh
okay i feel like he's you don't put him
it's like leo and all but you never put
jonah hill in there comedians never get
the same love
yeah i guess you're right but he's bad
but he's great in money ball he's green
wolf of wall street he's great in like
in serious roles too yeah that's true
he's great accommodating
yeah super bad hilarious
he was even great in his cameo in 40
year old virgin he was 21 and 22 jump
street are both great dude look at
christian bale's body unreal that's
crazy to get that skinny
crazy i mean that's medically
dangerous you think he was going to bars
during that time and women were like oh
this guy's gross yeah probably
damn i mean he did that matt damon did
that that can't be healthy no no the
weight fluctuation well how about
mcconaughey and dallas buyers club pull
up how skinny he was in that [ __ ] so my
lady has a huge crush on mcconaughey and
she said after that he was never as hot
like that [ __ ] him up yeah no i think
he permanently i can't imagine it's easy
to come back i mean he's still really
yeah look how skinny he is man wow
[Music]
crazy i couldn't do it isn't it funny
how like we could live in this you know
kind of overweight country and these
guys can do it i guess it helps if
you're rich and have a trainer well you
don't have a trainer for that you're
just probably someone being like don't
eat yeah that's probably the trainer
well what do they do like water and
lemon juice and cayenne like i wonder if
that would make you look like healthy
skinny though
maybe not maybe not i think you got you
can't work out either because you don't
want to build muscle you must be going
crazy
that's tough but imagine that first day
when you're done rap you're like give me
a [ __ ] ho-ho a ring ding a donut i'm
going all in yeah it must be way more
fun to just gain weight for a roll yeah
that's true like de niro and raging bull
or matt damon in the informant or
something oh yeah
good times lost 50 pounds and he was
already a pretty thin guy oh yeah
tapioca pudding and fish
as much wine as i wanted to drink
interesting is that that works huh
i guess he did look like a french woman
yeah throw a couple cigarettes in there
50 pounds wow
all the ones you didn't exercise for
five months
dude he was 136
whoa 135 damn
damn
yeah i feel like he had a spin because
remember he was
how to lose a guy in 10 days sahara uh
i hate my wife or whatever launch yeah
failure oh like turd turds movies and
then oh and then
out of nowhere he was just in like five
really good things in a row yeah and
people were like oh [ __ ] wolf of wall
street buyers club mud was good uh true
detective true detective killed it in
that
yeah he's great and then uh
uh what was that thing he did
oh he was in days confused so he started
out good yeah and then he was too hot
wow reign of fire i never saw
interstellar i heard that's great it's
good but it's heavy i mean it's three
hours of sci-fi
trippy nolan [ __ ] score is awesome yeah
i cried you cried oh i watched on a
movie you put me uh i can watch uh
finding nemo on a movie and i'm weeping
on a plane you mean i'm sorry what did i
say on a movie on a plane snake's on a
plane
yeah
um do you have any peeves
uh yes now this is a thing everybody's
saying now
and it's too much you know it's like
when people started saying uh let's
unpack this
you know once once everybody says it it
annoys me because i'm like get your own
thing but this is the thing everybody's
saying now and i hear it 14 times a week
one guy said it and now it's everywhere
that's another one let's table that that
was another people that yeah you're not
a therapist you're also not a ceo yes
why don't we why don't we settle down on
both fronts here exactly so this is the
new one that's bugging me and everybody
thinks they're so cool when they say it
i'm like my grandma's saying that but
it's uh they go
i'll tell you
that guy was cool
till he wasn't
everybody's saying that
yeah that situation was good till it
wasn't because it's not you're not
saying anything yeah that's how things
work they go from here to here things
change yeah things change people change
yeah exactly
mcconaughey was a good actor
till he wasn't yeah he's like all right
there's a lot of stuff on twitter like
that too i'm just like i gotta get off
this thing yeah yeah i know i hate those
tropes that start forming like blah blah
blah be like you know it's all there's
so many of them
i can't think of the other ones yeah
what a millionaire trying to think of
others like uh
yeah [ __ ] there's so many i know that's
so and we see him all the time and we
just kind of go oh that's a beautiful
matt what are other ones that are like
uh
like i think social media ones that make
me crazy squad goals was big like six
years ago everybody's squad goals squad
goals like all right and then and then
though t-h-o they'd be like that body
though
that was a big one
yeah it's like funny it's like bad
grammar is cool it is bad spelling is
cool it's funny it's like caring is so
uncool about anything yeah right i know
but i think it's like rapper speak or
whatever the hell it is
but yeah big
that's lit
oh yeah and there's all these tick tock
these trends that kick up and my girl's
like oh do you know about this trend i'm
like no
and i don't want to know because it's
going to go away in three days oh yeah
when everyone's like on tick-tock and
they're all like
yeah
they're all like naughty and you're like
yeah if everyone's doing it it's not
that cool no but originality is cool i
agree but originality isn't rewarded
because the trends build and build a
bill and then you you want to get in
that wave and catch
oh god here we go tell me without
telling me yes that was a big one oh you
know what else is annoying one uh
i'm uh i eat popcorn at a podcast old
you know yeah oh yeah you know that one
like uh i [ __ ] my pants
age or what what is it i'm blowing it
but i'm uh i'm i'm get uh i'm [ __ ] my
pants uh at a movie theater years old
yeah that's the one yeah there you go
it's like yes yes we got it um i'm uh
asked me if they uh trim my eyebrows at
the barber shop years old yes exactly
which i am by the way so am i
i would what else yeah tell me eight
years old tell me you're a murderer
without telling me you're just going
behind the person starts stabbing them
right right or it'll be a picture of
zack morris and it's like uh
uh
you know what what is it wanna feel old
and it's zach morris like bending over
with his back hurting or something
want to feel old no actually i don't
want to be old this actor you grew up
with has aids
feel old yet uh what else we miss you
charlie shade
there's sounds too that i hear from the
other room from my lady it's like oh no
no no
that was a big one
i know
there's some 45 year old guy listening
to this like i don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about
what else keep going up i hate people
that work at the bank i don't know what
this is uh yeah
i don't yeah man this is sad i don't
know this one main character trend
remember that what's that this
way do it play it
remember the dabbing no what
am i an idiot for not knowing this you
saw dabbing
a new amazing trend alert for you guys
this trend is called the main character
tick tock trend where you actually get
to display what kind of personality you
have and other characters that you can
relate to your personality this is a
super fun trend to create and in this
video we're going to be going over the
exact steps you can do to do this in
under 15 minutes not just that but i'm
also going to show the brands and
businesses out there how you can tell
because mike is on his forehead maximum
reach so let's get started
there are going to be simply three
pictures of things that you relate to so
that will be different characters
this [ __ ] is genius because it taps into
one ego
it's all about me oh
which celebrity do you look like and
then it pulls up and i'm like yeah you
don't look like that person no no yeah
you're not kim k what up what else is
there mad what are the other ones we
missed out on
because these are cracking me up
there's a million of them
i don't know any of this i don't know
any of this [ __ ] is
i wish they weren't tutorials i wish
they were just examples yeah yeah google
earth trend i don't know what that is
cherry bomb
huh
this is like this changes people's lives
too like people go viral off this [ __ ]
we don't even know what it means
what i mean when i say from
uh i'm from alaska that makes sense what
i mean when i say i'm from that's kind
of interesting because you're like all
right there's different vernacular in
different places maybe
turning your dms into quotes yeah see
that's another one you have to say slide
into a dm you can't just go you can't
just dm somebody you got to slide in
yeah netflix and chill was one i mean
now that now we're getting that's way
picture trend
what's that
uh-oh i hate that they're all it doesn't
i mean yeah yeah we're going in a
wormhole here
but um what do you think about when
people go like so popcorn popcorn
popcorn they get an ad for popcorn does
that freak you out yeah that is weird of
course it's like yeah the phones are
listening man you think of course is
that literal they're literally listening
to us right i mean
that's scary [ __ ] i mean
they the thing called like the facebook
security setting where it would just
come
uh set like you have to go to settings
and turn it off
or it would uh
it would felt like you ever on facebook
and you just see or instagram and you
were looking at sneakers on some website
and then you're scrolling yeah i mean
there's an ad for those yeah
that's what it is it's like the it would
follow you
whoa
i mean well it's it's literally the same
thing yeah but it's literally the same
thing as if like a dude just walked up
during the street like check out this
sweater i saw you checking this sweater
and you're like how do you right yeah
it's that [ __ ] it's that level of
creepiness yeah and you could turn it
off you said yeah oh all right i gotta
turn that off yeah you gotta turn it off
i'm getting all these gay porn ads on my
instagram
i gotta fix that
damn
this is scary and that metaverse is only
going to be worse i know because you can
like go shopping on the metaverse and
hang out with friends on the metaverse
and it's all just going to sell you [ __ ]
like well if you're in the metaverse you
got to pay the cover get in this
metaverse bar and you know it's remember
when simcity started and it was like
well this will be like an escape it's
like a funny thing and now it's just
life it's just life yeah totally scary
stuff it's [ __ ] scary uh
and we could push back but our curiosity
goes well maybe i'll try this metaverse
thing and then before you know it you're
buying a goddamn condo in in the
metaverse yeah before you know it you're
like uh
my name is what
that's not my name yeah that's not that
was another big one we're just people
like i was in this movie i was in this
movie it was just like a brag for actors
that's true yeah basically uh brody
stevens is act
hangover hangover too
that's a deep cut
oh you got a wreck because i got i got a
honker i got a good one actually and
it's connected to a recent episode so we
were talking about how good that show
winning time is on hbo i like i started
the book it's amazing it's better than
this
yeah you'll finish it in like three days
it's so good all right okay winning time
the book i think it's called showtime
lakers the dynasty but and it goes into
detail and the stories are insane and
holy [ __ ]
it's crazy in sports when the stars
align in that way right it's like uh
amazing owner and jerry buss amazing
uh character in kareem uh magic is the
most charismatic player and like you
know the most likable player but then
some [ __ ] behind the scenes you're like
whoa and then right right you know pat
riley's rise uh
you know the coach and what happened
before riley and before west had what
happened to him how crazy it is i mean
the book you will you'll burn through
it's awesome those sports books are so
like the the what was it bronx is
burning yeah i heard it's a good one i
have everybody raves by that book i
never read it but i heard it's amazing
i got to pick that one up but you can
tell adam mckay clearly read that was
like we're doing a show for sure this is
incredible sure it's awesome what a
career we would just make a show like
that it's so cool i know but he's earned
it he earned it what do you got i got so
speaking of hbo
now this is gonna sound niche but it
applies to everybody
the
tony hawk dock
i heard it's amazing it's incredible and
it's i know it's skateboarding i know
it's kid [ __ ] but
it is so deep and i didn't know how
[ __ ] up he was and
man talk about haters you forget this
guy he's a skateboarder whatever he's
famous everybody likes him he's got the
video game
they [ __ ] him they [ __ ] with him in
the beginning so bad skinny kid just
winning all these contests they would
throw beer cans at him other skaters
spit on his board
all this [ __ ] like almost got into fist
fights
and he just perceived pursuing why why
did people hate him so much because he
was winning
and he was nice and he was little and he
came out of nowhere and he would invent
tricks and they were like what the
[ __ ] this guy doing with easter i've
never heard of those and they got mad at
him but he's like i'm i'm making new
tricks well you know
it's fun and they got mad they're like
you're doing it wrong
you're weird
and he just kept going
wow yeah i heard the doc's insane it's
insane and i this is a leap here but it
almost says kobe bryant-esque where he's
like
first of all he gets knocked out twice
in the in the movie just showing like
head back knocked out hospital but he
just keeps going he goes back the next
day his wife's like what are you doing
you're gonna die his brother's like
you're gonna die you keep you got
concussions he's broken all these ribs
incredible you gotta i mean the
perseverance he has
a card a concrete bowl a swimming pool
just eating [ __ ] over and over and
you're like stop man but he can't stop
he wants to learn that trick what which
what's his streaming on uh hbo i watched
on hbo max i i couldn't the lady was
talking to me i divorced her i threw a
blanket over i was like i'm watching
this i'm all in
you can either get on me or you made a
tick tock while you're throwing a
blanket over
yeah i'm this year's old and i stuffed
the sock in her mouth that's not my name
that's not my name yeah oh no
but yeah great time so good and there's
a scene at the end where this guy rodney
mullen who's like the street skater
version because he's a ramp guy yeah and
rodney mullins is like he's like they're
like he's like i can't get out of bed
without eight things cracking he's like
i used to piss blood
and they're like why do you do this and
he's like because i know how much i love
skateboarding and every time my body
hurts i'm glad because it i it's heavy
you got to watch it you got to watch it
it's incredible neil brennan was
tweeting it i texted him i was like how
great was this you know wow i had to
like connect well i think i saw him post
it unbelievable
yeah moving
yeah no it's uh he was at the cellar one
night i remember and i just it's weird
when you're like because i don't know a
ton about him but i know who the hell he
is obviously and i know that he's a
legend and uh you see him in the in the
corner of the room you're like [ __ ] it's
tony hawk i better be funny yeah oh yeah
you met him i didn't meet him oh yeah i
think hanley met him oh but i i bolted
after my set but phil was hanging there
and he he i think got to hang with him a
little yeah and class act like the the
[ __ ] he could have done to people that
[ __ ] him over and then he he was so
nice that they eventually came around
and the 900 he nails the 900 on camera i
watched it as a kid live on espn with
like five of my buddies who we were
skater boy too big skater yeah so like
the 900 was huge i know i called you a
skater boy like
levine i'll see you later boy but uh
you're a skater big skater and uh i just
like the individual sports you know i
like ufc i like skateboarding because
it's just it's all you you know you got
to make it happen there's no team help
like comedy like comedy
so this really hit home and it's so many
comedy parallels which i say a million
times but uh tennis golf bowling any
other i love tennis golf is so slow that
i can't get into it i like that guy john
haley well john daly yeah that guy was
awesome he'd be a good guest oh
my god you got to get him on is he still
alive yeah okay he's still going strong
he would that would be a bert crusher
uh episode he would kill us he would he
had a great quote with tiger woods tiger
woods was like blowing up and they were
playing together and he goes let's get a
beer and tiger woods goes i can't man i
gotta i gotta work on my swing he's like
dude you're great let's just get a beard
he goes if i was as good as you i could
drink like you but i need to practice
wow and taylor's like all right i'm
getting a beer
wow yeah
fun fact yeah i mean that self-hatred
it's like you think it's safe
self-hatred is just for booze bags but
it's for tiger too oh yeah well there's
a reason why these guys are so good
the tiger dock was incredible incredible
loved it there's something so evil about
training the kid since he's like two
years old
it really is like
if you're if you're the same people who
get their kids into acting it's like do
they ever turn out normal never is it
ever a good idea no child actors are all
[ __ ] uh even the healthy ones are kind
of [ __ ] oh completely yeah i mean look
at the the webster guy
was the guy i mean lindsay lohan is fine
but there's others that have really had
a hard time yeah britney spears they're
all going through something do you see
she's having a baby oh great she told me
she wasn't keeping it
you know that her dad is like the second
i let you out of this prison you gotta
go and get knocked up was that amanda
bynes went nuts remember her her parents
i think i don't know i couldn't tell i
think her parents might have been trying
to help her or was like britney's i
don't know enough about the story but
like i know britney it's like man that
guy although you see her it's funny the
second she uh
was let out of the conservatorship she
posted two nudes on instagram and there
was there was a part of me that was like
maybe he was running a tight shift oh
yeah no maybe he knew yeah protect the
interest
yeah i don't believe in like like making
somebody a slave but
he might had i mean i saw her clam
within like 20 minutes
webster the other one different strokes
the older brother the black guy would
you tell me willis no it would the
brother of him
todd bridges he became a heroin addict
crackhead he had to go to rehab all
those guys they're all [ __ ]
we might be drunk is sponsored by better
help online therapy relationships take
work a lot of us will drop anything to
go help someone we care about we'll go
out of our way to treat other people
well but how often do we give ourselves
the same treatment for me
working out or buying some new sneakers
is an investment in myself this month
better help online therapy wants to
remind you to take care of your most
important relationship the one you have
with yourself
we're in therapy we go to the same guy
it's necessary clean out the garbage
your head has all these horrible
thoughts
splicing your childhood traumatic
experiences you're a wreck you're a mess
you need therapy get out the garbage
whether it's hitting the gym making time
for a haircut or even trying therapy
you're your greatest asset so invest
time and effort into yourself like you
do for other people tell them how better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't have to see
anyone on camera if you don't want to
maybe you got a weird boil on your face
or something you're weird you know you
don't want to see that you're all said
yep it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with a therapist in under 48 hours give
it a try and see why over 2 million
people have used better help online
therapy we might be drunk is sponsored
by better help and listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
drunk that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p-com
drunk
you got to do this it's therapy very
important take care of yourself it's
going to change your life here here
hey we might be drunk is brought to you
by fume fume is the safe way to quit
smoking handcrafted fumes 100 canadian
maple inhaler is made to comfortably
replace the hand-to-mouth habit
simply insert one of their non-addictive
flavored cores
cores come in dozens of flavors like
peppermint or lemon berry bliss i got
one of these things
it feels good to hold it's it's a cool
looking little uh wooden
contraption and you just want to hit it
all day and it this this thing works and
it smells great it's aromatherapy and an
inhaler
uh there's no smoke no vape no nicotine
to worry about even if you're not trying
to quit smoking fumes
cores can help with relaxation energy
and more it just feels good to put that
puppy in the mouth and give it a give it
a suck give it a whirl folks tell them
how fatty it's like a kid uh on a flight
to orlando you want to hit it all day
whether you're a smoker or an ex smoker
who still struggles with cravings fume
is the perfect tool for you it's time to
create positive habits and quit
naturally with fume and we're here to
make it easier right now if you head to
breathefume.com
drunk and use promo code drunk you're
going to save 10 percent off your entire
order you're going to save on the
cigarettes you aren't buying and save on
your initial purchase of fume that's ten
percent off your entire order when you
head to breathe fume dot com slash drunk
that's b
r e a t h e f u m.com drunk and use code
drunk
yeah
bad bad don't let your kid go on the tv
yeah that's not a good idea because you
start up here
and it's like women and drugs and coke
and money and then the show ends and
you're like [ __ ] and fame is bad fame is
bad
it's not good no it's not healthy bad
drug
whoa we await the end no no no we gotta
do some news stories you guys want
breaking news we gotta do some new
breaking news breaking news
what gilbert godfrey just passed away no
what
no way
what the hell's going on here
does the second comedian die while
taping
wow
67
his dirty jokes album we were talking
about it recently it's one of the best
it's one of the best albums yeah
unreal i opened for him once at
caroline's
he was struggling for the first half
hour because it's like carrie grant said
to
whatever and then
it was like all right that's funny and
then halfway in he's like i'm going
dirty and murdering
that's what they wanted and the jokes
are great
god damn it wow
that's another one gone
you know i didn't know him well but he
was always super friendly when you see
him soft spoken not not what you would
think yeah
and they made a documentary about him
which is great that's another wreck god
crazy horrible i know
i'm glad i got to say i worked with him
yeah but uh i did a zoom with him during
the pandemic and i remember teasing him
and he was he was in his pajamas and i
said you look like you escaped a mental
hospital and i got a big laugh at him
and like you're like it's gilbert it's
like it feels good like he's i remember
growing up with him in the problem child
movies remember that [ __ ] yes of course
i mean that laugh was iconic
oh yeah i did jimin sam with him once
and he was he barely spoke he just
laughed he gave he gave it up for
everybody sad man wow
we got to get a picture of him
on the wall
holy [ __ ]
67 did he have cancer
he had something
i know he was ill
wow
glad we got that duck i mean you watch
that duck
and they [ __ ] from him from the 80s he's
so alive he's so ballsy so reckless it
was [ __ ] awesome
it was like that old school comedy where
he just
he grabbed the camera and ah you know it
was very like uh
erratic and fun
he had uh he had a wife and kids yeah
so you know thoughts with him that's
horrible
his wife is super nice super cool yeah
damn oh there's bob saget and uh
wow
bob saget norm louis anderson now
gilbert
who am i
man
shout out to already lang once again
hanging strong
you got to give it to him
should we let's do some news stories to
maybe lighten this a little bit cause i
don't want to just yeah down here
what do we got thanks a lot matt
fisherman finds odd creature
out at sea that uh people think is a
baby dragon
robert fedortsov was fishing in the
norwegian sea when he found a bizarre
looking creature and after sharing an
image of of it online people were
terrified and said it must be a baby
dragon damn
that is a [ __ ] up little animal that
is maybe it's time for uh maybe it's
time for a new fish at the jewish deli
i want a bagel with a quarter pound of
baby dragon on it ah yeah it sounds good
baby dragon it's a good flavor yeah like
uh what's that other one uh white fish
well no it's like a flavor dragon fruit
dragon fruit yeah it just sounds like
ooh i'll have that
but baby dragon yeah look at that thing
so do we know what it is or is it just
ugly i don't know some of these have you
seen some of like this guy's i've seen
this guy stuffed before and some of the
fish
like they look so weird well they're
aliens you know you gotta think this the
earth is here then space says aliens
supposedly and then the ocean has aliens
yeah
ocean's [ __ ] nuts all kinds of stuff
going on down there it's also hilarious
to let people name it's a baby dragon
like people just hold up they're like oh
this is the pocket uh [ __ ] fish right
here
i prefer the blowfish
but yeah that's true i guess you get to
name it that's one of the perks of
finding a weird thing
he loves this [ __ ] though he must love
what he does you don't do this thing no
if you don't love animals i have no
water love
i mean i like to sit in the hot tub
every now and then but or like go maybe
i'll hit a jet ski but
some people just love being on the water
i'm not a big water guy i'm very city
i'm yeah i'm not like me too
i wish i had more love for it but uh
i like to look at the national park and
go see the the
the hills and the cliffs and the bluffs
but
give me an hour there and i got it yeah
people love nature but that that [ __ ]
ain't fun that is yeah oh my god it's
weird yeah what uh what else you got
what other news
you want to do this one we could be a
perfect match jet blue and spirit are
pairing not as odd as it appears ceo
says jetblue airways the new york based
carrier for its in-flight tv lineup
uh free wi-fi trendy snacks has made an
unsolicited 3.6 billion offer to buy no
frills spirit well if they can buy it
and
kick it up a notch i'm all for it yeah
but don't stick with the spirit
credo because it ain't pretty yeah it's
create a
credo spirit's terrible this is uh
it's terrible
whenever i ride a spirit airline flight
i walk up to the toughest looking guy in
there and beat the [ __ ] out of him just
to send a message
yeah the snacks suck the seats are like
wicker and the [ __ ]
they they get you on the baggage thing
they're like all right sure your ticket
was thirty eight dollars pretty good
price and you're like you're damn right
and they're like but fifty dollars to
check that bag and i'm like well i'll
put in the overhead they're like that's
eighty dollars like god damn i'll use a
seat belt that's another two hundred yes
exactly it's so i mean it you know what
you write it's if they if they bump it
up it's actually great
what do you mean if they make spirit
better oh sure because spirit's horrible
i mean
it's kind of like
it's kind of like when someone great
starts dating someone horrible and
you're like well are you gonna are you
gonna make them better or are they gonna
make you work right it's like it's kind
of like we were talking about brittany
early this is a spear is kind of like
kevin fetterline
right you know it's like what are you
gonna is this gonna get better yeah it's
like kim k and kanye are you gonna make
him better is he gonna bring you down
and
obviously they split yeah yeah 3.6 is
that a lot for an airline i don't know
what airlines go for i mean i don't
think it is i mean delta would not go i
mean delta would go for so much or yeah
you know united or american or something
right but spirit's a smaller airline
that's the thing is like two smaller
hubs coming together yeah yeah that's
true maybe it's a good thing because
jetblue is pretty good
jeff blue is [ __ ] good you ever done
that mint i've never been a man i did it
once game changer it's uh jetblue is it
feels very egalitarian yes there's
something about it that's uh cause some
of those flights don't even have first
class right it's just everyone with a
little more room it's like this utopian
yeah uh society julia mccullough had
that great joke he's like man jet blue
is very egalitarian like i was on a last
week he said the word of god no i
couldn't think of the word he says i was
like damn did i just pull a julie
mccullough a bit by accident no but he's
like i got on it and a kid was walking
down the high the hallway going uh or
the aisle going hey i got peanuts uh
dollar for oreos you know i gotta do my
basketball team we need uh we need
jerseys oh that's such a new york joke i
know this is great that's the cool thing
about jetblue is they're a new york
based so if you do the mint they're like
this is a from this food is from frank's
restaurant on third street these cookies
are from magnolia bakery like they do
all the new york stuff so you're getting
all this premo new york food you do feel
like a kid when you're on those flights
oh you're doing like a [ __ ] cookie
yeah you're like kevin mcallister
uh plain passenger said he'd pay extra
to not sit next to woman with odd ritual
all right let's see what we got here
what are we thinking flicking the bean
i think you pay extra to sit there
that's not my name
[Laughter]
okay
oh that's pretty clever
is that an odd ritual let's look wait
i'll do it again i think it was the feet
thing
oh she's got these little weird feet
hammocks
and then a giant head pillow that you
can lean on facing forward well it's
probably actually yeah first off i've i
don't love the bare feet on the flight
no especially you better be hygienic as
[ __ ] if you're doing that yeah but i
have no problem with it other than i
mean a dude with
bare feet
deserves a death penalty a woman
misdemeanor yeah
yeah i'm with you
because i've i flew to china i don't
know five six years ago did some gigs
over there flew coach hardest thing i've
ever done in my life
coach to china and the chinese have
different rules like at one point a
guy's barefoot came through
my seat and hit my uh
armrest barefoot on my armrest and i was
like what the [ __ ] and i told the
the what do you call it flight attendant
she was like oh yeah that's that's
normal the sign of respect in our
culture yeah so i gave that guy a couple
of elbows like hey watch that foot there
uh
kung pao or whatever the [ __ ]
whatever his name was that was that
wasn't his name it definitely wasn't as
[ __ ]
uh oh here we go marjorie taylor greene
reports jimmy kimmel to cops after will
smith joke oh my god you see everybody's
a snowflake about something everybody
likes to call everybody snowflakes
especially on the right and then they
get snowflaked about other [ __ ] well
she's nuts wow your jewish space what's
the joke she's my favorite female
comedian but yeah she's nutty yeah what
is the joke here
jimmy kimmel's been going for it lately
has he oh yeah
is especially upset with the three
republican senators who said they'll
vote yes on judge katanji brown jackson
who's nominated for the supreme court
she tweeted murkowski collins and romney
are pro-pedophiles i just voted for kbj
wow where is will smith when you really
need him huh
[Music]
is it a good joke not really is uh
is
but also it's like it's kind of i think
it's pretty offensive to call someone
pro pedophile oh yeah for sure because
she was she wasn't hard is it because
she wasn't hard enough on uh
on some cases as a as a lawyer is that
what it is i guess so well you know it's
like uh by the way was that would be
hilarious if will smith did slap her
again if he just like his publicist is
like dude you slapped another person
he's like i can't yeah he's like it's my
thing now
i gotta do my thing so she get her done
so wait she reported that go what is it
what'd she do
she's suing him i think she's suing him
oh it called the police sorry that she
didn't really call the police did she
she called the police that's what it
says capital police after late night
host
by the way the capitol police we've all
seen they don't really uh they're not
really on it
but yeah
this is this is she's she's cuckoo she's
off uh twitter i think they got knocked
her off yeah that's how she called the
cops
i will say on a side note what's the
name of the the new cantanji brown
jackson it's so funny when i see comics
like
good for her i love this lady and you're
like what are we doing here you're like
hyped up about a a senator or a senate
seat like how much do you really give a
[ __ ] i think the answer is they probably
don't and they need something i think
you're right
it's great it is historic i mean
that's i think that's where people are
like it's the first black woman ever
right on the supreme court so i think so
i think that's so that is meaningful but
this is how i do that hey the first
black woman got hired on the supreme
court oh cool
all right i'll get the uh the pastrami
on right like i don't know it's just
weird that they it's their whole well
you're not a sentimental emotional guy i
get i get emotional but not about my mom
but this is not my mom yeah it's just
some lady who's i've never cared about
the supreme court i personally don't
connect to it but i also i get why it's
like a historic moment for me i get the
historical yeah i get that
but are we gonna do that for every
historic moment hey we got our first uh
trans
cabbie
or whatever i don't know it's like
sure where does it end
all right well i want to see that post
oh yeah i'll do i'll do a post for him
okay for her
what else a new oklahoma law will
criminalize abortions whether it takes
effect depends on the supreme court all
right well let's see what she does
criminalize abortions
so yeah this is crazy so now it's like i
mean yeah texas and oak oklahoma now
you're gonna have to go down to mexico
yeah where they do allow it i believe
oh yeah um they don't say anything they
don't say no to anything
they actually built an abortion clinic
right next to a senora frogs
so you can make a whole weekend out of
it you get a yard stick of rum and uh
and you take care of [ __ ]
yeah there you go that's two and those
two states are touching
yeah dude
so they might have a baby they might
[ __ ] yeah and they might have to keep it
and i hate to tell you texas but you're
a bottom
literally uh britney spears said she's
pregnant there you go the 40 year old
pop star announced the news in an
instagram post there you go i mean pete
davidson is at it again
well it's also kind of you know what's
kind of crazy is like
this is what happens when you do the
conservatorship like you're there people
are
they're they're forced in i don't know
the situation i know nothing about
britney spears i know
if i were gay or a woman i'd know
everything but i'm not i'm neither yeah
so um
yeah dude i mean yeah let's go to it
who's the guy yeah who is he
it'd be funny if it was federal line
again oh [ __ ] this guy keeps coming back
well he made a fortune on that divorce
did he oh he cleaned up he and he
invested all his money in wife beaters
this guy's rich everyone's rocking tank
tops yeah right what else
good looking guy oh yeah okay is he a
model or something sam
oh he's an actor okay
quote-unquote actor
there she is louisiana's own britney
spears prego yeah she's from kent
hopefully she'll get pregnant oklahoma
yeah right
there you go
hey well that's a you know is that a
white guy i can't tell
what do you think
i don't i don't know
i don't think he's white six two maybe
he's indian with that name oh iranian oh
they're hot
yeah they are good looking dudes
wow look at this guy on the boat
holy [ __ ] yeah he's a hot guy yeah you
gotta have a baby with that specimen
jesus christ britney brittany what do
you think would you
well
for the story but
i don't find her that like i knew girls
growing up who were hotter than her
young britney was pretty hot though
young was pretty hot yeah but look at
that i mean she just looks like a
regular like a tgi friday waitress you
know
not knocking her we're losing our female
on gay base right now they're just like
look we're done with this podcast um
yeah i mean she i think she's a
beautiful woman but yeah i mean she's
yeah i mean that's that's like a
a lady who works at a tilted kilt you
know that place i don't know oh it's
like a irish chain bar she she uh yeah
she was never like my crush growing up
she was never yeah but definitely above
average
yeah a hell of a dancer and talented and
all that crap
so good for her
yeah yeah don't don't don't abort it if
you if you don't want i mean you know
what do whatever you want do whatever
you want yeah kill it who gives a [ __ ] a
florida teen was killed as he and
another teen took turns shooting each
other
while wearing body armor whoa
florida baby damn
hopefully it was uh
hopefully it was bought actual body
armor not the drink that they were
wearing but uh under armour they filmed
it would you watch it what what
no play it well i don't have a video
it's for like a youtube video
what facing charge is both 17 years old
he had another teen took turns shooting
each other while we wow
where was that i didn't i didn't realize
someone died holy [ __ ]
so he's going to jail i feel like
it was consensual
damn there's a video
let's see it
if we can it's not out yet
it drops on patreon um
i'm i'm never shot my friend and body
armor years old
oh no
oh no
oh no no no
i love the uh the tough guy dad you know
the the dads who hate uh participation
he's like back in my day we didn't wear
body armor we just shot each other these
kids are [ __ ]
nowadays all right wow the man suspended
of shooting lady gaga's dog walker was
mistakenly released from jail the
suspect was released from jail
after a court hearing due to a clerical
error authorities are now on the hunt
holy [ __ ] a clerical error this sounds
like a plot of like a bad adam sandler
movie
[Laughter]
damn it he's back on the street i want
our best man on him it's tommy lee jones
yeah did we do the fugitive but it's
about a guy who just shoots a little dog
oh no he didn't shoot the guy right
he kidnapped the dogs oh yeah because
they were worth a lot of money yeah so
he shot the guy yeah that's a bummer
when you're below dog
right right
i feel like if you're gonna steal
something a lady gaga's dog trainer
isn't exactly the toughest guy you know
i feel like if you're you're in charge
of those two little twinkie dogs i feel
like it's not some guy got paid though
he got shot i'm sure he did hold on
popcorn the dogs are worth they were
worth like you know 400 grand each or
something they're like show dogs damn
dude damn clerical error
pretty good
that's why you gotta get excel is that
it that's all the news
good news dude yeah
good news bad news for the for the guy
clerical yeah well you got a bit let me
see i got a bunch of ideas what do you
got i got an idea it's totally not
finished but i think i got something
here
what do you got
um so everybody now likes to tell you
their thing you know it's like as a
woman as a trans immigrant as a black
man and i'm like i'm gonna treat you the
same either way so it doesn't really
matter to me what you are
but
i'd rather you tell me your mental
illness because i'm that's actually
helpful like as a narcissist as a
sociopath as a
whatever
that that i can use as a bipolar person
so you should start introducing with
that [ __ ] instead of your race or your
gender or your sexual orientation
problem is the narcissist don't know
they're a narcissist yeah yeah huh maybe
we say
yeah well i'm a i'm
you know mexican you're like yeah but
you're also a narcissist and they're
like what did you say you know right
right
there's something about like uh you
gotta claim all of it you can't just
tell me your ethnicity you gotta tell me
your disease as a depressed person
yeah why do they do it why do they do it
as just uh
that's interesting because they'll be
like i read this news story and as a as
a hispanic woman that affected me and
i'm like
ah
i don't know it affects everybody
i get it but like you should be it
wouldn't be a lot more helpful if they
were like as a
narcissist this this bothered me and i'm
like of course that that makes sense
yeah so i don't know what the funny is
he say as an ar as also a narcissist
it's nice to meet you right right yeah
that should be i mean that's really
people should have to lead with that
[ __ ] always yes because there's so much
mental illness now and there's so many
different sex it's like very diverse you
know
also if you if you told me that at least
i'd be like well this person's probably
in therapy yeah
you tell me your race just doesn't
like i can tell you race that's true
that does nothing for me yeah it doesn't
help me at all i i knew you would that
race right exactly i knew you were a
black woman you don't have to be like as
a black woman i already got that
give me the the mental illness you got
you got to be honest about it too you
can't just be like as a ocd i'm like no
no i want the real [ __ ] you can only
tell they're being honest if it's bad
right as a manic depressive as a thief
i identify as a thief yeah as a
pedophile
like wow this [ __ ] this pedophile was
honest yeah
as a compulsive liar whatever it is like
this everybody's got their own was a
compulsive liar doesn't even help you
because you're like well is he lying
right now maybe it does help you a
little because you're like point good
point
this popcorn's [ __ ] good i know it's
so good but that's that's my jumping off
point so uh once i figure out some yeah
as someone who identifies
i feel like it is interesting i feel
like young people now do identify more
with their mental illness oh yeah
because it makes them interesting yes
exactly it used maybe the angle is it
used to be about your race that made you
interesting and now you got to take it
up a notch
now it's kind of like okay but
now it's like it used to be as a black
man i was like as a uh bipolar black man
yes exactly oh [ __ ] it's like when
people tell you like you know i'm bi and
you're like i don't care
that doesn't make you any different or
better or worse in my eyes but if you're
like
as a bipolar yeah now we got something i
got something there with the buy the
bipolar henley's got that joke oh he
does [ __ ] what's his hanley's is uh
he said he was writing out the pros and
cons
for his girlfriend and and he wrote uh
pro by
khan polar oh that's a great it's a
great joke that gets a laugh on the buy
that's a great joke
damn all right well that's out that's
out yeah but i'll i'll noodle
noodle buddy all right hit me i got a
few ideas let me see what i got here
because i'm [ __ ]
[Music]
um
trying to see what else because i have
like a few that are almost hitting
um
oh man we have 800 gilbert ticks ugh i
know
um
this isn't so
a lot of these are jokes that i've
either done on here or i'm doing on
stage and they're either working but
they're missing some things i'm trying
to
um
yeah a lot of these are ones that i've
either tried here and i keep adding to
so i'm trying to think which ones
um
uh
lay it on me baby well this one i tried
originally on the i told her the story
now i'm doing it on stage and it's
hitting so i want to maybe see if i can
add to it but uh
it's a story about me and gary going
through security
and the woman is awful of the other
woman oh yeah you know when we say like
lady enough and you know in that right
story she goes this doesn't concern you
and i say you know it does and then she
yells out security and i'm like they all
[ __ ] hate you woman yelling at all
the tsa yeah she's yelling at everyone
security i'm like you just cursed you
yelled at all them yeah i hate you and
then uh
and then you know gary my friend gary
chimes and he goes this isn't the movie
your life you're a nobody
which that gets a laugh on stage i'm
saying that and then she goes well
you're short yeah and he goes ladies you
should see me without my shirt on i was
like dude we had her yeah that's the
line that hits and then i say uh
we're professional comedians we could do
better but you know in that moment you
got to have his back so i'm like he does
look good without a shirt yeah you got
to like back him up
yeah
but uh you're scrambling but i don't
know what the next like i i have a
couple angles i have or like part is
like um
one is like we went in there trying to
like
we we went in there seeking justice to
stop this woman for being rude to tsa
but did you just end up looking like a
gay couple
you just end up being like like he's got
a good body you should check him out
that's funny and and the other angle i
had is either that or
like how we're professional comedians
and that's what we hit her with like
pathetic
it's like both of those are great well
the other angle is like it's like
literally like we are really good at
insults that's our job yeah
quick with insults and this is what it's
like it's like if you got into a fight
with an mma fighter and right as you got
into a stance he just [ __ ] his pants or
something ah that's good
i don't know well the funny thing is now
you're killing with it
so it's almost like yeah we're comedians
but you gotta let me have some time to
write
you know you can't pull out a desk and a
chair while she's talking you know uh
also there's something interesting about
we talk about terrorism this lady is
like a mini terrorist yeah she's
terrorizing there's no security for that
[ __ ]
yeah that's how white women terrorizes
yes yes you always think about al-qaeda
but you don't think about uh yeah yeah i
don't want to say al karan because
that's [ __ ] too easy
i know what i'm not doing it don't do it
but it's like but al qaeda got through
security yeah that's the and she can't
even get through you can't even get
through security that's that's funny
yeah baggage blah blah blah
yeah she's got yeah but like the idea
that
a terrorist
this is like the misdemeanor version of
a terrorist right
this is like uh
we won't blow up your uh we won't blow
up your plane but we will [ __ ] up your
afternoon yes yeah
don't blow up your plane but we will
[ __ ] up your morning yeah
i like it
yeah i'll play with it there's stuff to
noodle with there yeah like [ __ ]
popcorn i can't stop i know me neither
i'm sure the people at home really
appreciate us uh chomping this whole
episode i tried to chew over here but
yeah i [ __ ] up it's so good thank you
van navs
yeah that's funny that's a lot there you
know you can you can't have liquids on a
plane but you can have an attitude
something you know yeah there's a lot
there
no security for [ __ ]
uh i'll avoid that one
i'm like well you lady or a [ __ ]
everyone applauds that's how i picture
it gunther
it's a horrible airline
everybody's got an attitude
uh all right well hey good app good
stuff
hit the patreon we're cooking i mean i
feel like we've been just banging with
the guests yeah and the apps and the
might be drunk at gmail.com
yeah we got merch send us gifts whatever
you got we'll put it on the goddamn wall
i think we're moving soon or we already
have moved so
we'll put the new address up well what
dates you got there national albany
toronto
chicago i assume will be sold out by now
uh east providence rhode island tampa
cleveland houston
west palm buffalo you get it
samurail.com shows you the best we love
you guys hell yeah
i'm all over the road as well in may
of this month we got uh addison improv
and dallas one of my favorite clubs love
that room bricktown comedy club in okc
classic uh san jose i think he's getting
moved for some tv [ __ ] staying up
live in huntsville alabama going back to
the south minneapolis mini uh minnesota
the pantages let's sell that out
chicago's almost sold out maybe we'll be
by this time cleveland i need a lot of
help cleveland come on out we'll go to
the casino we'll do it up we'll go to
what is it slotsky's what's that place
called in cleveland it's like that uh oh
uh
it's like a diamonds slimens yes yeah
that's corned beef baby great and that's
coming from a new york jew baby
bon secours wellness arena no idea oh
i'm doing some bert shows i'm going to
the drag way in bristol tennessee the
greek and la
uh all kinds of fun stuff irvine improv
and cali in july so yeah come on out say
hello get a shirt get a glass toast it
tilt it
drink it up we love you love ya
[Music]
sunday's close
i've had a little too much
[Music]
and naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
way
we might
be
true
[Music]